la france poursuit l'utilisation du
vaccin astrazeneca au personnel soignant
de plus de 65 ans hier l'om est ça
justement apporter son soutien au groupe
pharmaceutique britannique en
recommandant un usage de son vaccin aux
personnes de plus de 65 ans astrazeneca
qui publie aujourd'hui le doublement de
son bénéfice en 2020 3,2 milliards de
dollars va écouter le président du
groupe du conseil stratégique des
experts de l'eau avait ce même s'il ya
une possible réduction du plein impact
de ce vaccin dans sa capacité de
protection en particulier contre les
formes graves de la maladie
il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas
recommander son utilisation
même dans les pays où circulent des
variants nous recommandons toujours pas
l'usagé des vaccins pour les voyageurs
internationaux
nous n'avons pas assez de vaccins pour
pouvoir faire cela et nous ne pensons
pas qu'il s'agisse d'un groupe qui
devrait tout d'abord voyagé inutilement
et ensuite qui auraient besoin de cette
protection spécifique du vaccin